seit gut zwei Wochen gehen die Menschen
insbesondere Frauen in Iran auf die
Straße sie protestieren aber nicht nur
gegen das Kopf den Kopftuch Zwang
sondern auch ganz grundsätzlich für die
Freiheit und für Frauenrechte ja den
Podesten schließen sich immer mehr
Menschen an darunter auch Studierende
mit folgen denn gestern gingen die
Sicherheitskräfte in der iranischen
Hauptstadt tehan mit Gewalt gegen
Studierende und Professoren und
Professorinnen der sharif-universität
vor es soll insgesamt seit Beginn der
Proteste bereits 130 Tote gegeben haben
ja und Auslöser der Demonstrationen ist
der Tod der 22-jährigen Mascha armini
vor gut zwei Wochen die 7 Polizei hatte
sie wegen ihres angeblichen
unislamischen Outfits festgenommen was
mit Amini danach geschah ist unklar die
Frau viel ins Koma und starb am 16
September in einem Krankenhaus fragen
wir nach bei unserem Korrespondenten
durch dort in Istanbul einen schönen
guten Morgen Glück können diese Proteste
dem Regime jetzt wirklich gefährlich
werden
also auf jeden Fall ist der Druck höher
als je zuvor bei anderen Protestwellen
das steht außer Frage gestern hat der
Revolutionsführer das ist der oberste
Machthaber in dieser Islamischen
Republik Ali hamine zwar mit den
üblichen propagandahülsen versucht das
Ganze etwas zu überspielen er sagte das
sei nur kleine Gruppe von unzufriedenen
angestachelt natürlich wie immer vom
großen Feind Amerika und Israel also aus
dem Ausland gesteuert aber dann sagte er
auch ganz unumunden es gehe um die
Unabhängigkeit und die Autorität eines
islamischen Iran also offensichtlich hat
die Macht Elite begriffen dass das was
grundsätzlich ist hier es geht ans
Eingemachte es geht an das
herrschaftsmodell der Islamischen
Republik das sind junge Leute teilweise
Schülerinnen die wir da sehen in den
Videos auf den Straßen in Teheran zum
Beispiel die verlangen keine kleinen
Reform mehr oder irgendwelche
Verbesserungen des Apparats sondern die
wollen das Regime loswerden die ist ein
Regimewechsel sie schreien ganz laut weg
mit der Diktatur das gab es so noch
nicht in Iran das hat eine neue Qualität
und Glück jetzt hast du gerade schon
Bilder angesprochen es ist ja gar nicht
so einfach verlässliche Informationen
aus Iran zu bekommen weil eben die
mullas die Internetsperre zum Beispiel
eingeführt haben also es ist wirklich
sehr schwierig da durchzudringen bringt
das eigentlich irgendwas diese
Abschottung
leider ja muss man sagen also es ist für
uns als ausländische Berichterstatter
sehr schwer an zuverlässige
Informationen zum Beispiel über das
Ausmaß der Proteste zu bekommen das hat
auch damit zu tun dass ein enormer Druck
gerade ausgeübt wird auch
Journalistinnen und Journalisten in Iran
die versuchen genau das zu ermitteln
also wie weit wie groß sind die Proteste
wir wissen dass in allen 31 Provinzen es
Proteste gibt aber das genaue Ausmaß
oder Zahlen gibt es nicht eben weil
jeder der versucht das zu ermitteln oder
über die Proteste zu berichten in Iran
sofort festgenommen wird dann die
Internetsperren es kommen also Videos
wirklich nur tropfenweise über
verschlungene und sehr gefährliche
Umwege ins Ausland auch da wissen wir
nicht genau ist das eigentlich das ganze
Bild es man darf annehmen das wesentlich
mehr abgeht auf den Straßen in Iran als
das was bei uns ankommt also diese
Sperren und dieser enorme Druck der im
Moment vom Regime auf die eigenen Bürger
ausgeübt wird der zeigt schon Wirkung in
der Form dass wir eben nicht genau
wissen als beob was im Land vor sich
geht soweit die Einschätzungen unseres
Korrespondenten live aus Istanbul vielen
Dank und wir bleiben dran